our next speaker shortly after college
she became a part-time
DJ please welcome Tanya uh first thanks
Jared for inviting me to speak here
whether or not that was a good idea um I
didn't know what to pick for my walkup
song so I let chat GPT choose for me and
I was gonna it was between early '90s
hipop or um Taylor Swift but I let chat
GPT do it and it came up with Imperial
Death March so you're going to see
random Yoda mid Journey art for no
apparent reason um has nothing to do
with the content just my talk inspired
it so uh I always like I always hope
that someone like learns something uh
even if it's tiny when they walk away
from listening to me for 20 minutes um
so hopefully you learned at least
something here whether it's technical or
process oriented uh but if not you can
enjoy the mid Journey art at the very
least um so bit background about me my
name is Tanya cas ali uh my background
is formerly in computer science and
biology I started using R back in 2005
at Children's Hospital and was really
just thrown into the deep end um they
were like just here's some gene
expression data figure stuff out between
Mouse normal brain models and cancer
brain models and I was like okay um you
know yeah there was like essentially the
cray documentation back then I feel like
a you know Boomer sometimes saying this
but yeah it's it would was like you had
to learn a lot just like dive in and do
stuff uh so it was scary but you know'
come a long way um I've worked at a
couple biotech startups out of college
uh we were building really sophisticated
cancer models of disease and perturbing
the system with drugs to understand what
drug will work with a patient given
their genetic makeup um so really cool
stuff I think was ahead of its time
honestly um this was like bioinformatics
I feel like was the OG of data science
really uh but anyway I moved from there
and did some non-healthcare stuff in um
non uh Healthcare Rich Industries like
Telecom Finance went back to healthcare
and Biogen and started my company TCB
Nyx in 2015 uh I don't want to spend too
much time on on my and that's my dog
pork chop he's our chief security
officer so to give you an idea of the
project team I'm the founder of TCB
analytics uh our client is sports
Innovation lab we work with clients from
Pharma to the Department of Defense to
kind of all over the map but Sports
Innovation lab has been a long sing
client and their goal is to acquire more
fans for uh teams and entertainment in
venues and so on using data and their
client was the Washington Wizards of the
NBA so here's how this whole thing
started was I started getting peppered
with just completely non-contextualized
random data asks and I'm sure how many
of you has that happened
to right okay a good amount of us and it
looked like
this it was like are they sport Sports
betters uh what luxury Brands they spend
the most on is the NBA Community growing
and these are literally word for word I
copied them from a document um so I used
our famous and here's a little Yoda he's
working late he's really pissed he's
like what what do these people want so I
used our famous corporate phrase we all
love let's take a step back right makes
you sound really smart and try to
identify some patterns within these
questions like what are they trying to
do is it longitudinal why do we care
about longitudinal are we comparing
things are we trying to look at
frequency of shopping are we looking at
spend so there's so many different
things and when people throw vague
questions at you I always say just try
to get the context but so what so we're
closing the gap between that and what
data is actually available which I'll
get into in a second identify patterns
within those questions if you can uh
this is a pattern here and we threw out
essentially those four pages and just
just started honestly fresh uh with a
real data products initials uh
requirements meeting in like our in our
first technical meeting because I was
hit with this and just had to go back
and figure out what the heck they were
doing turns out the Wizards want to sell
more tickets okay could have said that
to start with right and they want to
identify high value fan segments of
course you want to keep your loyal fans
you want to have your high value fans
spend more and so on great
before I get into the data uh this
method of rapid prototyping is something
I've been pushing for years people are
probably sick of hearing me talk about
it but uh we found a lot of value with
it it it's working really well with a
couple of our Pharma clients right now
it allows you to demonstrate all the
value before you build a full product
allows non-technical customers to get
involved early on in collaborative
sessions uh they can quickly see their
feedback come to life so they feel very
involved in the process and you get
better adoption that way I feel like
when you build data products to get them
involved early on and you don't want to
build something you want to disappear
for three months four months five months
do this whole waterfall method and come
back and build like a Ferrari when they
wanted a Jeep Wrangler
right it's a dumb analogy but you know
you get the idea so you start with
something that they can use it gets
better and better over time and you
quickly iterate and that's what shiny is
so good
at so the data the data is uh 20 billion
credit and debit transactions uh from
2016 to present it's on 26 million
consumers in the United States and
they've tagged I call about over 5,000
Merchants so to give you an idea here's
some of the fields below you've got a
member ID uh the date of the transaction
the transaction ID they they bought
something Popeyes we have the amount and
the state it happened all this so you
can imagine
with 20 billion of these and tracking
people over time you can just learn so
much about where people are actually
spending their
money Sports Innovation lab layered on
an IP kind of on top of that with these
custom communities where we group
together the merchants into leagues and
teams and concerts and you name
it but then how do we quantify this in a
way that's smart so if you just look at
like where people spend their money it's
always top Merchants Walmart Target uh
Amazon
PayPal the payment facilitators right so
you need to find what's different so we
need a we need a segment to compare to
so the way we do this is we want to
quantify the fans we care about or the
segment we care about against the
general population and in this case the
general population is our entire uh
database of
transactions now you can get fancier you
can compare it to maybe a regional
Regional group or you can compare you
know D to New York fans and so on
but in general there's this idea of a
marketing index which is used to Target
uh people in ad campaigns and it's kind
of weird understand so I wanted to draw
this out but basically if you've got a
general population let's pretend it's 10
people two people shopped at
niky 20% of the Gen pop shopped at Nike
Wizards fan base six out of 10 and we
know that size is going to be different
right but this takes care of that uh so
your index would be that percentage
divided by the the other one our index
is 300 so basically the Wizards fans are
three times more likely to exhibit uh
the behavior shopped at Nike than the
genp so now you can do this over any fan
segment uh any time range any community
and so on and we've done some really
cool stuff with this with the WNBA the
national women's soccer league um and a
few I think the MLS is coming
up okay so I'm going to risk a live demo
now this is After figuring all that out
this was kind of the first
iteration and hopefully you can see this
but basically these filters are not all
here right these these built up over
time we started really basic I just got
kicked because my internet has been a
little funky hold
on let's see if we can reconnect love of
live demos
always all
right and if not I have screenshots as a
backup but it will be nice to walk you
through try one more I was having a was
having an issue in the back trying to
connect all right well well that may be
loads go back to here basically we've
got a bunch of filters on the left side
that were added over time first it was
just give me the people that shop
shopped at the Wizards NBA Store for
example uh then they wanted to know High
income low income then they wanted to
know the fans home cbsa if they live in
the DC area then they figured out
actually we want to group this by a
different grouping maybe not a category
but our custom Community uh and so these
things just keep coming in right if
you're building a product like this you
know how that goes the requirements just
it's like a flood opens up a Floodgate
as soon as you release this to your
users and they're super excited
so what this does it allows them to do B
basically all of those questions you saw
it saved me a bunch of time I'm not
going to sit there and write you know
custom queries all day this enabled the
users the marketing experts the analysts
to do this stuff on their own I'm all
about you know self-service and
enablement and not having to like be a
query you just a query person in the
back room so building a solution that
actually streamlines what they're doing
as well learning about their process
they're doing all this manual stuff in
Excel I'm like I can we can totally do
that for you like in a shiny app um so
it sorts by the index and then you can
sort by a whole bunch of other things
you can sort by the frequency of the N
the national gen pop versus the Wizards
fans and then you get a little chart
when you click in of a drill down if I
want to know what are they doing in uh
news and print media we can see the
athletic right we can see New York Times
and we can see exactly how it Compares
and when you'd say well maybe we should
Target the athletic with our keywords or
our marketing campaign or whatever it is
let's see if it I'm just going to check
one more time if it did come up no the
internet doesn't like me okay it's
okay so just I I like to throw in a
couple technical tidbits that I learned
along the way what helped me as well so
uh we have a queries. r file where I I
started to store the SQL in kind of
chunks and every time an requirement
would come in I could just add another
query and
so you can see from the shiny um inputs
the input cbsa here is mapped over here
it might be tough to see but we've got
that kind of mapping to the queries and
then we use glue the art package which
is super handy it interpolates uh SQL
strings for you and so it does this
really nice thing too if you select
multiple values you put an asterisk at
the end it will create the instatement
for you with the Escape quotes and
everything so that was a really I I kind
of backed up and refactored because I
knew this was going to keep coming in
these requests and I wanted to it's like
saving your future self right some
headaches so glue package was really uh
helpful and this is something new that
I've never done before but I added I
exposed the SQL that's generated in the
shiny app on the front end because
remember this is an internal facing tool
it's like a market research streamline
tool so it enabled the business analysts
the data analyst to quickly help us test
uh paste the SQL in snow flake see if it
works did you catch anything a join
condition that was wrong just exposing
and being transparent about what's
happening is going to help you fail
faster find bugs faster uh because we're
they're a small team we're a small team
we're not bringing five people to build
this thing with a dedicated QC tester
it's not you know we're we're doing this
stuff fast and in an agile way so that
was really helpful um and you can see
where the filters are being mapped to
the sequel as well the year uh the
merchant and being and so
on and then this was actually my first
time using memo wise which uh for
performance and you can see Yoda is
sprinting because he's so fast uh baby
Yoda I actually should say grou uh but
the items you can specify a cache time
so expires after 24 hours because I want
the DAT let's say the data updates every
day we want to expire that
cache if you have a long run function
and where you remember we're querying
almost a terabyte of data 26 billion
rows most of our queries are a few
seconds some joining the certain tables
are 10 20 30 seconds so what you do is
you take your long running function and
you wrap memo eyes around it give it the
cache and assign it to a new function
name and then every time you call that
function you use that new name and you
give it all your inputs and if it's
already been run that day it's just
immediate and that's just really nice
performance thing if your user if you
know your clients are demoing you can
run it ahead of time and it'll come up
right away so memo eyes uh cool
package and I think I'm I'm good on time
right my timer restarted the basically
the the takeaways here are that we now
with those communities we understood
what Wizards fans were doing we we
segmented them in all those millions of
ways that the marketing team wanted us
to do but the tool allowed them to do
that they could take High income they
could take DC fans they could take
um fans that were Wizards fans and also
shopped uh for online dating services
it's very
flexible so they came up with these
these takeaways like a push for more gen
Z trying to attract more new Young fans
they noticed that Wizards fans were
interested in the MLS two times as like
to show an affinity for the MLS over the
general sports fans long
story there was a two times return on ad
spend after using this program and as
data scientists building data products
we that's like the Holy Grail we proi uh
so I thought this was really cool so
without our data the camp the Facebook
results that they ran had a
$29 Roa roaz if you will uh total spent
of 58 grand total revenue 123 Grand with
our targeted data with the shiny app
mind you like just a shiny app that we
built in I'll tell tell you how quickly
it it went the total span was 25,000
Revenue was 110,000 they had 111%
increase in return on their Raz uh so
cool Yoda's baby Yoda's very
happy so takeaways again we went from
that idea I got we got peppered with
these questions we went back to drawing
board we built an MVP in several weeks
uh literally from before Christmas they
were using it the first week in January
and we had a ran a successful campaign
with the Wizards the NBA team three
months later and and then uh after this
they actually ran one with the capitals
so the whole Washington DC Sports um
teams there and we've been running these
now with the
WNBA uh as well as MLS is coming up so I
think the point is always ask so what
don't just answer it's it's tempting to
just write the sequel and disappear but
honestly I think it's going to be more
work for you in the end because they're
going to just keep asking you for random
things and if you can get the context
and piece it together in a way that's
intelligent uh as well as visually make
sense for what they're trying to do like
what what is your client going to do
with this why do you want to see spend
overtime I mean a lot of people and they
won't be able to tell you it's an
exercise that they're going to start to
think about in their head most
challenging challenging aspect of the
project was the human element right
shiny made this all super easy getting
those requirements was the hardest part
It's usually the hardest part of my job
every day is
people but yeah I I call Consultants uh
Consultants are basically like corporate
therapists
and we make people we make people talk
to each
other so rapid prototyping is also this
important Bridging the Gap thing that
shiny just enables data scientists to
focus on what they're good at and build
products quickly and you'll be amazed at
things you don't think about or you will
never think about when building data
products um you know once you start
building there's little little things
that come up that are just impossible to
predict um that said here's the art
packages for reference um just three
that I mentioned that came in handy for
us for this project and thank you very
[Applause]
much